All right. Let me show you how the Template works, real quick.
I've got this file called front.html.
It's currently blank.
I'm going to type in some HTML.
We've got our DOCTYPE--you know--
our , our /ascii/,
We've got our here,
and inside our we've got an tag,
which is just--basically, it's called a HEADER1.
It draws your text
bold, a little larger--
with a little margin around it, and that's it.
So that's in this file called front.html.
If we had opened this in our browser,
it would just print the words: /ascii/
and let's go ahead and instead of loading this in our browser,
return it from our file here.
Instead of calling self.write,
I've changed this to self.render("front.html"]
and let's give this a whirl.
Okay. Here we are in our browser--I've reloaded the page.
We can see my title is set to /ascii/
and we've got the text, /ascii/, up here.
The slash is just kind of a joke.
That's how Fortran does their titles and stuff.
In our Editor, you can see--we just called the
self.render function, which is defined here.
All that does is it calls
render_str on this Template name--
this file name which render_str loads,
renders--and then we write.
Okay. So, simple enough--that'll just save some time.
It's a little bit more convenient to edit HTML
as HTML--especially if you're editor is going to help you--
than to have a big string in the middle of your Python file.
All right. Let's go over to our HTML,
and the first thing we want to add is our form.
So the method="post"
and we're not going to define an action; we're just going to
submit to ourselves, which is something we've done a lot.
So I've added one input field.
We're going to call it "title"--
and I'm going to include "title" in a little here,
just to put it on a new line,
and then it's going to be an
and this is going to be for the title of our image.
Let's go ahead--and I closed the tag.
I'm going to Save the file, and let's load it in our Browser
to make sure everything's working.
Okay. Here I am in the browser,
and I reload and now I have my title string
and a box I can type in.
Okay. All is well.
Let's add the next form field
for inputting the art from the user.
So we're going to call this "art",
and let's interrupt this for a quick quiz.
Which is the most appropriate form element for inputting ascii art?
Is it ,
a ,
a element,
or ?